welcome to the show everybody it's gonna
be a really fantastic one actually
i couldn't be more excited we're kicking
things off with a super-sized drew's
news with an extra special guest yeah i
can't wait till you see who it is
because we caught a big fish all right
so let's get right to it hit the
headlines
[Applause]
[Music]
of that good news train and with me at
the desk is the best news plumber in
town it's rock matthew
hi
everybody news plumber all right yeah
you caught a big fish huh oh yeah we did
and actually i'd like to go live um to
our special la correspondent it's oscar
winner business maven and host of the
new series sex love and goop ladies and
gentlemen gwyneth paltrow
[Applause]
it's also the prettiest coolest most
amazing
woman on the planet just she checks
every single box i love you
[Applause]
i'm watching i'm sweating good i want
you to sweat and i gotta tell you as
much as i'm proud and humbled to call
you my friend you've known rossi even
longer
yeah is that crazy true story i always
loved you you know this and my very
first oscars when i was covering up for
jay leno back in 2002
i met gwyneth and i said will you be my
best friend and she said yes and she
emailed me the next day and we've been
besties ever since that's a true story
look at us
i mean you just
you are the complete package and so much
more and i'm so excited
to talk about some relevant headlines
and actually our first story is a big
fish in the sense of it is about the
marvel universe
harry styles is joining the marvel
universe
that's right everybody's favorite boy
the coast
reports that he's on board to play
arrows the god of love and sex
i mean how perfect is this and it's
rumored that we can get a sneak peek of
arrows in the newest marvel movies the
eternals directed by chloe zhao out
november 5th now in the comics arrows
can fly he's got superhuman strength and
he has the power to
stimulate the pleasure centers
in the brain where was your mind going
sorry
um
of anyone within 25 feet now i know my
pleasure center is very jazzed about
this casting
um
gp you're a marvel maven what do you
think
this makes me want to dip my toe back
into the marvel universe right
maybe pepper potts can intersect with uh
the hairy styles of it all
you know he is he's playing the god of
love and sex this is what they call type
casting because
he looks like he knows a thing or two
about a thing or two about both of those
things if you know what i mean
this just might be too much to handle oh
i can handle it
by the way how does one in the marvel
universe interpret a god of love and sex
how do you like how does that work in
the marvel world well i mean that you
just ha you just cast harry styles and
then you just you know put him without a
shirt on and there you go you're
absolutely right and apparently the
casting director agrees roster story all
right gp what about this we're keeping
it spicy we've seen a lot of hollywood
couples snoogling in public lately there
have been some hot and heavy pda from
travis barker and kourtney kardashian
we've seen them everywhere megan fox and
machine gun kelly
they've been do a hardcore pba but is
this level of pda for everyone well a
writer at cosmo tried it in her
relationship and she said it actually
increased her libido and pumped up her
self-esteem just by showing a little pda
so gp do you keep it pg
i think i tend to keep it pg
in public i don't know maybe it's just
um
maybe i should maybe i should loosen up
a little bit you know and
and uh make out in public i don't know
maybe not were you ever that type
because i used to totally pda like
when you're dating fabrizio moretti of
the strokes i was just constantly making
out with him i couldn't handle it
i was like i couldn't i couldn't get
enough you know
were you ever pda i also did pda with
fabrizio
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and i'm sure those curls just went a
spray
here's my feelings about it um i think
there's an age gap or an age limit like
right i i do think that when you're
young you can just chalk it up to
freedom idiocy and hedonism
but you get to a certain age and it's
like
here's me at a dinner table with people
pdaying
this snitches your face when you see pda
now i'm old and jaded and i want to be
like pack it up
move it to the bedroom sister i'm trying
to eat
all right next up golden ager speaking
of are still going at it too in fact i
guess here's our answer and they say
it's even better the good news network
reports that a recent survey of people
over 50 found that 45 percent said sex
gets better with age ross gwyneth um
what do you think i well i want to be
very clear i am grateful for any sex
that i get to have but i
i do
i'm just grateful
my friend we are grateful i wouldn't be
grateful to have sex with you too right
okay yeah don't you hope gp that you're
out there when we're older just really
getting it
yeah absolutely and i think
older sex should be awesome like why do
we have to
i don't know pack it all up and and go
home
when we have all of this hopefully
healthy life left to live just you know
with more wrinkles
oh yeah well finally let's talk about
this usa today just tackled an
interesting relationship question is it
strange if i want to be friends with my
boyfriend's ex
well the resident therapist sarah kubick
says it's fine as long as you evaluate
why you want that friendship and then
make sure your boyfriend is totally okay
with it but it is an interesting
question so you get in a relationship
with somebody their ex is still a friend
or around there can you do that are you
capable are you friends with
your with brad's exes i
i feel like
i don't know but you know me i'm all
into this conscious uncoupling thing and
trying to keep
good feeling and good sentiment between
people and
we don't have to come to a situation
thinking like oh it's an x so therefore
i feel threatened or i'm gonna you know
be predisposed to think negatively it's
like what if we just said like hey the
more the merrier and
and not create negative feeling and try
to create more positive feeling where we
can so that's what i try to do it sounds
super simple it would be beautiful but i
understand sometimes it can be uncomfy
and sticky and weird i think that comes
out of insecurity yeah i do i have no
insecurity with
will and his wife ali in fact i wish i
could be best friends with her but i got
some good advice like not to you know
kind of
be too present in their relationship we
found just the right sweet spot and i
believe
i believe in this yeah that's beautiful
drew i think it's amazing that you do
that i think so too i think it's
beautiful i do watch a lot of 90 day
fiance and i will say that you guys are
the minority okay a lot of people find a
lot of drama and so this is very evolved
you're thinking and i don't think that
it's i don't think it's the norm i think
people are really uncomfortable in these
situations with exes and this and that
the rules are so blurry do you even know
what 90 day fiance is when or she does
of course i watched one brad and i over
quarantine watched one whole season dude
i've never been more proud of you than
ever
[Applause]
[Music]
you